yeah we know the fortress does have
limited seating for tonight's game as
we've been talking about small capacity
but there is a local venue creating what
it calls
an immersive watch party alex yes and
hector mejia is live there near hacienda
decatur with a look inside and some
really yummy food hey hector
hey there we just finished sampling the
food and before we go any further good
morning to you guys let's just go ahead
and hit it
that is part of the immersive experience
here at diversion of you
abused vince it's a new venue here in
the valley by hacienda and decatur
offering
private tables along with food and
drinks on game nights and joining us
live we have karsten zane mixologist
here
all right so we tasted the food earlier
now we're going to talk about what good
morning
morning
hector um today we're going to feature
two cocktails first off is gonna be
called the gold fashion
gold for golden knights yup you got it
connect the dots right there
all right so what do we have here so
this is our gold fashion should be a
gold fashion made
with the official partner of the golden
knights gold bar whiskey this is
actually a award-winning whiskey made in
california
sounds golden what are we going to make
next next up i'm going to make for you
right now it's called the golden egg
cocktail
it's going to be a gin cucumber sour and
in this one
we're featuring whistling andy cucumber
gin distilled in montana with fresh
ingredients and also
a very interesting product created by a
local mixologist
her name is mariana mercer barini it's
called electric
dust all right so as you work on that
drink tell us about the vibe here before
you sprinkle that dust there tell me
you know what do people say when they
come out here and watch the games oh
it's a great time it's
right now with a pandemic people want to
watch it but they just can't because of
the rules
so we offer them a venue to do so and in
this venue we have uh
a lot of pinball machines we have drinks
we have desserts uh they're they're
delicious we just uh
ate almost an entire table and what's
also special is that they have specialty
nights coming up in
april uh for teachers nurses first
responders to get a free ticket on
specific nights we'll be posting all
that info
uh soon on our website eightnewsnow.com
but okay so what's that dust on the side
of the uh
of your the glass do you get to lick the
glass or what yeah it's really
interesting so it features a
flower which changes your taste buds a
little bit creates a numbing feeling
if you've been to the other properties
in vegas
they have this featured as well so it
really does numb your mouth
it does it does and it also changes the
profile of the drink so you taste one
thing and when you taste it again
with this dust on top of it you get a
whole new drink and you're just paying
for the price of one
what does that dust taste like looks
like candy
bubble gum sure
a little flowery bubble gum i guess
we want to make that drink another cool
thing to highlight too is it's a
it's a non-smoking non-smoking venue
tickets are about 79.99
for each person and you basically get to
bring along your friends
and you get your own private table is
that right yes you do
so you get to hang with your friends
your own private table watch the games
enjoy some great food and some great
drinks awesome
all right so what are we about to pour
right now so this is going to be the
finished product
the golden knight
double take this three
two running out of time one
less than one point seventy five point
fifty there you go
[Laughter]
the pressure pressure the pressure all
right so these are specialty cocktails
that people get to uh purchase right
in addition to uh what they get yes
you're correct
cool there you go man all right we got
our golden knife thanks for having us so
we have those drinks paired with food
here we have a bacon wrapped hot dog
and again this is just part of the
immersive experience here
and we're going to send things back to
you guys we'll be posting all the
details about the specialty nights which
are pretty cool giving back to the
community
specific nights free for teachers first
responders military members we'll post
all of that information
on eightnewsnow.com for now reporting
live hector mejia and
karsten z back to you guys pretty tasty
alternative to the fortress there hector
thank you very much sir that looks like
a delicious
uh 6 a.m cocktail thank you very much
we'll check it
later on